and
decayed
a grisly nightmare of macabre perception
greetings
i'm your host doug bradley
and i invite you to join me as we
explore scorn's mesmerizing labyrinth of
art forms
and somber tapestries
you awake
in the middle of a desolate hellscape
filled with biomechanical contraptions
part flesh
part machine
an industrial civilization
now lying in decay
and ruin
a hidden fauner sleeps within the
underbelly of the world wanting nothing
more than to be left
undisturbed
scorn has been carefully crafted with
great attention to detail everything is
focused on building a specific
atmosphere
from a unique organic ecosystem to an
unsettling soundscape created by ethec
and lustmord
[Music]
scorn has no dialogue so most of the
storytelling comes from the environment
discovering the ever-present symbiotic
relationships and how things are
connected equips you with the tools to
progress
while there is shooting within the game
scorn is not a shooter
every encounter must be carefully
considered
a wrong choice could be
deadly
i hope you've enjoyed this glimpse into
the twisted world of scorn
the team at ebb software can't wait for
you to uncover the secrets of this
unique world as you experience scorn
first hand this october
are you prepared to unravel your inner
self
within scorn's world
of horror
[Music]